so my thing is is like you talked about
like the new album and how it's like one
of your best bodies of where you think
it's your best body of work it is my
best body work because I've been through
like New York City the album took my
whole life to meet that right that it
made you without a deal most so major
what I do the album I always wanted to
make because it's a combination and a
combination of everybody I grew up
you're listening to them wanting to hear
him and rap and all my favorite rappers
I played Fat Joe in that [__] I had 50
Cent on this right every push it t five
like whoever everybody's on this [__]
Nori Prodigy you know what I'm saying I
made that album because I had the
ability and access to people Raekwon
right Raekwon was my favorite rappers
for sure you feel me so that's that
album New York City was album that I did
for the city
that can't that that'd be one of my
Greatest Albums Of Classic Albums to
people from New York City because I did
that for the city right I took my shine
and my highlight and I sacrificed for
the city I wasn't trying to appeal to
people everywhere else because I'm like
my city needs this I'm a sack I'm not
gonna jump on the south beat like
everybody else is doing just to try to
get on I'm a sacrifice and I'm Gonna
Stand ten toes down and rep for my city
but this album they hate I win this is
me going through my most tragic time in
life going through the lowest points in
life you know what I'm saying like like
total in the public eye and then
overcoming that and this [__] is like it
ain't just dead hater I want is dead
hater we want anybody that overcame some
[__] if you woke up this morning and you
got some level of success in these
people hating on you and you still
breathing still carrying on is dead we
won real [__] and ain't nobody in
hip-hop history that could has gone
through this [__] that I went through
lived survived and then been able to put
an album out with it do you think that
at times
the
spectacle of some of these beats you're
wrapped up in might take away from
people like diving into the album no
[__] I think it's the opposite [__] no I
I don't I'm gonna be honest I don't even
take the time like like I said I'm I'm
one of the most
um authentic
enroll
artists where I don't pick and choose my
battles I don't say oh come on guys this
might be not politically correct right
now let's not do this like I take the
battles as they come if I have time for
it you know what I'm saying so like I
even think did I win has allowed people
to see how lyrical Troy Ave is I mean
real life lyrical like
um um since you [__] like writing
letters here go one dear hater I won I'm
a boss you a bum like the breakdown of
that
this you know hip-hop
on that album I said since you [__]
like writing letters here goes one get a
pin I write this as a free man made paid
half a mill out the pen
I'm out of your league don't pretend
bowling on point like a pin I sat many
months you wrote To The Judge soon as
you walked in Mr Collins and his
Entourage me doing a lot of shootings a
recent one outside the New York City
Club pursue them and that was people
suing trying to take all our stack got
attempted murder because I took the gun
from him and bust back these ain't no
made up raps I'm paraphrasing the facts
I'm the king of the underground he's
just an underground rat I rose up above
the road and stay trying to pull your
boy back with a cold show then code the
hand whoever reaching gets smacked URL
I'm a w i and Lambos and Bentley's where
I dwell it's a mansion for sale I bought
that you just bought to a cell a real
[__] lives on while a fake one dies in
jail
I took the actual
Court documented statement from redstone
and put it in a song and made a lyrical
Mr Collins and his Entourage been doing
a lot of shooting it's not made up [__]
right that people do people make up
words bowling on point like a pin
everybody's no bars taking off
it's a mansion for sale talking about
where I dwell I bought that you just
bought to a cell like these are the
shits that people won't get or
understand so now when you got the light
on you and [__] oh or you got more eyes
on you people like oh [__] I ain't no
chill that was that dope and I see it I
got a podcast called facto show I see it
in fact because now I put out old
records that I put out a year ago and
[__] yo this is crazy yo I put
it out a year ago you didn't see it then
right it's cool you wasn't paying
attention
you late to the party but come on in now
enjoy it we we always we showing love we
spreading love and destroying hey